[Music]
the world was watching as some of
music's biggest stars poured their
hearts out on stage for the victims of
the Manchester terror attack thanks for
joining us Ali Fedotowsky mono is here
for Nancy O'Dell
it was such a beautiful night the one
love Manchester concert was a night full
of tears and resilience yeah in our
senior news editor Jennifer Paris was
inside the arena
arianna made a triumphant emotional
return to the manchester stage and it
was all the more impressive after they
learned that the singer made a risky
last-minute set change
the 23 year old rearranged her whole
show after Saturday's rehearsal she made
the decision after meeting the mother of
victim Olivia Campbell Hardy who was
killed in the terror attack and she said
that was some crying because Olivia
wouldn't have wanted me to cry and then
she told me that Olivia would have
wanted to hear the hit
this morning Ariana's mom Joan thanked
the City of Manchester and posted this
incredible concert picture I actually
saw her yesterday talking with Ariana's
fans in the crowd and you could see that
she was definitely feeling all the love
it actually turns out that even Ariana's
mom was surprised by the song that her
daughter closed the show
[Music]
Joan grande told variety I didn't know
she was going to sing it she went on to
explain that summer over the rainbow was
actually the favorite song of Ariana's
grandfather meanwhile you may not have
noticed this during Katy Perry's
performance
look closely right there her one love
dress included a photo collage of the
victims of the Manchester bombing the
three hour and 18 and it's a bet
included some incredible duet
Ariana and Miley and Ariana with her
boyfriend Matt Miller now that diamond
on her left finger right there started a
lot of speculation that the couple is
engaged but a source close to both of
them says no Ariana is not engaged and
finally one more big surprise Justin
Bieber in his performance was one of my
favorites of the night it was so
heartfelt and touching he actually
fought back tears during an emotional
speech to the crowd everybody said we
honor you and he loved you thank you so
much for having me guys
[Applause]
[Music]